[Music]
for a long time the Nintendo name
carried a hefty weight beginning in 1983
when it released the Famicom video game
console to the waning days of the
Gamecube
Nintendo's library was a virtual who's
who of video game icons even though we
the companies pushed to open its doors
to mass-market appeal became a mainstay
for families across the world but with
its next console generation Nintendo
would lose its way and its name would
lose much of its clout it's a system we
will all enjoy together but also one
that's tailor-made for you it was here
at e3 2011 where Nintendo first showed
major signs of confusion
the Wii U marketing strategy suggested
Nintendo didn't really know what the
console was or who it was made for it
tried to please to separate audiences
hardcore gamers who grew up with the
earlier consoles and families that
bought one or two games a year the
result was an unfocused platform with a
scarcity of top-tier games over five
years the way you did have some
fantastic moments from the novelty of
the shooter splatoon to the endless
creativity of Mario maker this isn't to
mention returning Nintendo classics such
as Mario Kart Super Smash Bros and a 3d
Mario game but these were few and far
between and aside from a select few
entries they didn't really make the case
for the Wii U's second screen function
the console also lacked the technical
capabilities to bring many third-party
games to Nintendo's audience in 2013
alone EA Ubisoft and Bethesda all
decreased their support for the Wii U
the console sales figures may be all the
evidence we need as of December 2016
about four years after its launch the
Wii U sold just above 13 million units
worldwide Sony's ps4 took one year to
reach the same figure while Microsoft's
Xbox one took slightly longer based on
its figures before it stopped announcing
them in October 2015 all in all Nintendo
the former Titan of the console space
had suddenly become the underdog from
2012 until early 2017
Nintendo relied on its fan
classic 3ds handheld to bolster the we
use slow adoption rates and lackluster
software sales in a cultural sense as
well Nintendo faded into the background
third-party publishers rarely spoke
about it new franchises didn't sport the
Nintendo logo good metroid games were
nowhere to be found and we hadn't seen a
new console Zelda since 2011 it didn't
feel as if Nintendo understood what its
fans wanted but now here we are in 2017
and what a turnaround it's been
when in Tendo first revealed the switch
it seemed like a completely different
company it revealed this new console
with confidence knowing full well what
it could do and who they had made it for
its opening trailer was corny yes but it
was a clear message for people watching
Nintendo had combined the home console
and the portable handheld and it was
more than just a gimmick for a long time
Nintendo had stake its name on
innovative game design over a powerful
hardware and the switch is no different
it's less powerful than in Sony and
Microsoft counterparts and Nintendo has
made no attempt to hide that fact
because the truth is it really doesn't
matter true to its name the switch can
transform seamlessly from a livingroom
console to a very powerful handheld
device it's not just a second screen
like the Wii U was but an alternate
portable screen with gorgeous games you
can play on long flights road trips or
even on your commute the switch feels
like when Nintendo wanted the Wii U to
be but with better hardware and more
importantly a strong software lineup to
support its first year 2017 is a major
comeback for Nintendo it's on pace to
sell just as many units in his first
year as the Xbox one did and although it
probably won't match the ps4 worldwide
it is crushing Sony's console in its
home country of Japan comparing the
first 26 weeks of each console
side-by-side we see that the ps4 sold
almost six hundred and sixty-six
thousand and the switch 1.5 million now
there are many factors at play here but
as someone who has loved Nintendo for
most of my life and felt as if it lost
its way during the Wii U years I want to
point to three things it's doing
amazingly well first off its reshaping
its roots while many law didn't endow
for releasing amazing games in two of
its most legendary series I think it's
even more impressive how it has adapted
its origins for modern palates breath of
the wild isn't just one of the best
Zelda games but I would argue it's the
best open-world game ever made metroid
Santa's Returns doesn't just recapture
the series sense of exploration but it's
one of the best 2d Metroidvania style
games in a time when they release every
few months
what's more Nintendo seems to be
remoulding its roots with Mario as well
it hasn't released yet but from the 2
hours I've played of Super Mario Odyssey
it's reframing how its world works
giving us explorable sandboxes rather
than discrete levels to jump our way
through Nintendo isn't afraid to give
its iconic franchises massive overhauls
secondly Nintendo is working well with
third-party developers whereas the
company seems sheltered during the Wii U
years it's been coming out of it's shell
lately look no further than Mario +
rabbits Kingdom battle in one of the
most unlikely marriages ever Nintendo
has partnered with Ubisoft to bring us a
turn-based tactical combat game with the
Italian icon and the eccentric rabbits I
never thought I would see Mario rabbits
and XCOM combined but here we are and
it's one of my favorite releases of the
year and if you had told me one year ago
that Nintendo would partner with another
developer to revive the classic 2d
Metroid formula I would have laughed but
it did and not only as mercury steams
reimagine Metroid to amazing but if it
sells well it could make the case for
more 2d metroids down the road and of
course we also have rocket League to
look forward to and as of last week's
Nintendo Direct Wolfenstein 2 and doom
but that's the previously drop their
support for the Wii U but seems like
they're back in full force for the
switch lastly and I think this is the
most important thing in Tendo is doing
well it's listening to its fans the
switches dedication to veteran Nintendo
players is almost proof enough that the
company is taking its audience's
feedback the console has gimmicky titles
that showcase its unique capabilities
such as one - switch but by and large
its first year has a much stronger focus
on deep triple-a games and the Wii U did
we have zelda splatoon - and Mario +
rabbits as well as the upcoming Super
Mario Odyssey we also finally have a new
2d Metroid and a new Metroid Prime to
look forward to these are things fans
have been clamoring for in droves
wondering when Nintendo would finally
pull out its big guns and say what you
will about the limited supply of the NES
classic and snez classic but as of today
Nintendo has announced that it's
extending production of the Super
Nintendo into next year and bringing the
Nintendo classic back next summer
they've had problems with supply over
the past two years but this is a step in
the right direction I think in several
years we'll look back on two
17 as the turning point for Nintendo the
year when it finally showed us it was
listening the Europe pulled out all the
stops and the year it showed us it could
still be a Titan in the console space
the Wii U felt like a failed experiment
right off the bat and in 1000 didn't
give us much to be hopeful for over the
next five years now I'm playing games on
the ps4 and Xbox one and wishing I could
have them on the switch it may not have
the power of its counterparts but
Nintendo's platform has become my
favorite machine to play games on over
the course of 2017 and if you prefer
playing on Sony or Microsoft's consoles
than Nintendo's comeback is nothing but
good news for you as well the company's
success will encourage competition and
innovation and creativity across the
board and that's nothing but good news
for all of us
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]